pour aller plus loin avec nous sur ce
plateau stéphanie villers bonsoir
bonsoir bonhomie c'est christian
bourroux bonsoir vous êtes président de
l'union française des retraités
vice-président de la confédération
française des retraités jean sébastien
ferjou bonsoir mâcha directeur de la
publication d'atlantico et gilles robert
yedder vous êtes conseiller confédéral
cgt en charge des retraites merci à tous
les quatre d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
est ce qu'on vit trop avec l'idée que
les retraités sont pauvres alors que
d'un point de vue macroéconomique c'est
faux stephan ziegler si on regarde
effectivement d'un point de vue
macroéconomique on voit que le niveau de
vie des retraités est un peu supérieur à
celui de des personnes qui sont en
activité donc on peut pas dire que le
système tel qu'on l'a construit notre
modèle social à défavoriser les
retraités par exemple mais il ya
toujours des cas extrêmement bien sûr
mais je parle au niveau en moyenne c'est
simple par exemple le revenu minimum
vieillesse est de 800 euros il va être
portée à 1000 euros alors que pour
quelqu'un 1920 ce sens il va être portée
à 1000 euros à comparer avec le rsa
inquiets le revenu minimum pour
quelqu'un qui en âge de travailler qui
ne travaillent pas qui lui est à 550
euros
donc on a eu tendance quand même à ne
pas oublier nos seniors et et à les
inclure dans notre modèle social
question bureau quand vous entendez cela
moi j'ai pas l'habitude de contester si
vous voulez des chiffres indiscutables
juste un tout petit point
il me semble que la comparaison que vous
faites c'est quand vous parlez des
actifs vous incluez les actifs c'est à
dire y compris ceux qui sont inactifs
face de dire y compris les chômeurs
c'est à dire que si on fait une
statistique n'est pas moi qui l'inventé
elle sort de de l'insee si vous voulez
si vous prenez les retraités avec la
population active en emploi on aboutit à
ce moment-là à des chiffres légèrement
différent où le niveau 10 voulait des
retraités est inférieur à celui des
personnes en emploi
c'est une petite précision 1,26 voulait
pas un mot n'est dit les retraités sont
pas si riche gaza ce que je dis
simplement c'est que effectivement par
rapport à une époque ancienne dont
certains peuvent avoir la nostalgie vous
les retraités étaient misérables
il ya eu une amélioration régulier
est intervenue de la situation des
retraités des personnes âgées
que ce soit les femmes où que ce soit
effectivement les hommes donc il ya eu
un effort constant de la part d'un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques pour améliorer la situation
des retraités
faut-il s'en plaindre faut-il revenir à
la situation où les retraités étaient
vraiment enfin une partie importante
dans la misère retraites était vraiment
misérable
ce n'est pas du tout notre avis et j'ai
souvenir que certains responsables de
sites là c'est du lourd tel d'été par
exemple considère que d'avoir les
retraités et les actifs en parité de
niveau des niveaux de vie faut bien
savoir que le niveau de vie c'est pas le
pouvoir d'achat le niveau de vie c'est
pas le revenu niveau de vie c est une
construction statistique que beaucoup de
personnes connaissent mal et d'après ce
que je crois savoir les derniers
chiffres du niveau de l'eau monte à 2014
jean sébastien ferjou on comprend que
les retraités ne sont pas si mal loti
que cela est ce que pour autant c'est à
eux d'assurer la justice sociale ont
repéré pour les autres mais la question
est plutôt à l'envers c'est est-ce que
c'est aux autres battus mais là où tout
sera l'occurrence les salariés puisque
en l'état le régime des retraites
fonctionne principalement pas seulement
puisque la csg assure déjà une part non
négligeable du chemin du financement en
question mais en l'état sont quand même
les salariés qui payent pour l'ensemble
de la population donc après on peut se
poser la question justement est-il
normal dans un environnement qui est
plus difficile que les salariés à eux
seuls
d'autant que ça pose des difficultés en
général économique pour les entreprises
parce que ça fait ça renchérit beaucoup
de coûts du travail
donc la question la csg elle est déjà
venu essayer de régler ce point là et on
est face à un choix effectivement est ce
qu'on veut une solidarité universelle et
c'est le projet qu'a exprimée emmanuel
macron ou est-ce qu'on reste sur un
principe d'un régime de retraite tel
qu'il avait été conçu initialement avec
des actifs qui payent pour des inactifs
sachant qu'à l'époque la démographie
était quand même totalement différente
et que d'une part y avait des gens qui
n'avaient pas de carrière entière début
des régimes de retraite et il y avait
beaucoup le rapport entre actifs et
inactifs était parfaitement différents
donc je pense qu'il n'est pas inutile de
se poser quel que soit le choix
philosophie d un réseau de se poser sur
la lune et on va entendre emmanuel mâcon
dans un instant je voudrais d'abord
entendre gilles oberrieder qui ne s'est
pas exprimée encore lui c'est ce que
vous venez de dire la retraite est quand
même en rapport avec le salaire qui est
touchée par les actifs c'est vraiment
une prestation sociale qu'est en rapport
avec le salaire
il est quand même extrêmement compliqué
nous poser des questions d'universalité
ou de financement par l'impôt puisque
dans tous les systèmes de retraite
on a en fait du financement qui provient
du salaire c'est une assurance sociale
ça a été conçu comme une assurance
sociale à deux régimes oui juste un
petit mot le président macron que l'on
cite n'a jamais parlé de faire financer
les retraites par l'impôt et ben si
c'est un danger vous nous étions un
système de répartition
il a réaffirmé que la répartition devait
être la base du système jamais n'at-il
envisager de parler et la csg n'a rien à
voir avec les retraites et maliennes la
crau connaît parfaitement le sujet il a
été lui-même inspecteur des finances et
rapporteurs en 2008 d'un texte sur la
répartition des prélèvements
obligatoires entre générations voici ce
qu'il déclarait c'était en mars dernier
lorsqu'il était candidat à la
présidentielle mon objectif ce n'est pas
de faire aujourd'hui des économies sur
le dos des retraités ou de ceux qui vont
partir en retraite
je ne modifie pas à l'âge de départ à la
retraite durant le quinquennat je ne
modifie pas non plus les règles et pour
les retraités et pour nos concitoyens
qui sont à cinq ans du départ à la
retraite
je garde le système de retraite par
répartition et donc celles et ceux qui
travaillent financent la retraite
retraités mais c'est beaucoup plus juste
et transparent à la lueur de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui stéphanie vilers ses
déclarations ce qu'on a l'impression est
ce qu'on a le sentiment que magna mâcon
se dédit quelque peu non parce qu'en
fait son idée globale par exemple sur la
hausse de la csg parce que par par
contre ça il l'a annoncé il là il a
proposé au sénat ce qui est ce qu'ils me
proposent il dit j'augmente la csg pour
tout le monde de 1,7 pour cent pas
uniquement pour les retraités
ce qui va me permettre de retirer de
supprimer les cotisations salariales des
salariés qui pèsent sur leurs revenus
alors c'est libérer du pouvoir d'achat
pour les salariés du secteur privé est
effectivement en contrepartie demandée
une solidarité supplémentaire de 1,7
pour cent pour les retraités les
retraites les plus élevés 1 c'est pas
pour tout les retraites voilà l'esprit
de la mesure
mais ce que dans cet esprit il n'y a pas
une forme de stigmatisation des
retraités est presque une rupture d'un
pacte social entre générations et d'une
lutte d âge jean sébastien ferjou bon à
mon sens non parce que pour revenir ce
que j'ai toujours bien sûr que la csg
n'a pas vocation à financer les
retraites mais la question posée était
celle du niveau de vie ou du des
retraités pour le coup la csg ça à voir
avec avec ce point là non je ne crois
pas je pense que le monde change le
rapport démographique on l'a dit a
changé et où les retraités doivent s'y
faire mais ils doivent s'y faire mais de
qui parlons nous parce qu'il n'ya pas
les retraités ces moyens statistiques in
welchem en rien dire il ya quand même un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui aident
pas spécifiquement les retraités mais il
ya des efforts qui ont été faits y
compris pendant le quinquennat hollande
sur la complémentaire maladie
universelle justement pour des gens
ayant des faibles revenus
donc la prise en compte il ya des
retraités pauvres et pia les retraités
et en attendant c'est comme quand on
parle de fonction impression tous les
fonctionnaires sont des infirmières ou
des militaires comme s'il n'y a pas des
secrétaires qui servent à rien dans non
mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est que là on mélange
des choux et des carottes en quelque
sorte on peut poser la question du
niveau de vie de gens qui n'ont pas eu
des carrières entière ou qui bref pour
des raisons différentes ont des
retraites effectivement très faible mais
il ya le minimum vieillesse un million
de choses que de poser la question pour
l'ensemble des retraités pour l'ensemble
des retraités
il me semble que en plus en vie dans un
environnement économique est beaucoup
plus difficile maintenant il est
beaucoup plus difficile pour des actifs
maintenant d'avoir une carrière entière
que ça ne l'était il ya quelques années
donc pour des gens qui ont eu des
carrières sans trop de problèmes
oui participer un peu la solidarité
nationale ça peut avoir du sens et la
csg s'inscrit aussi dans cette logique
là la csg pour le coup qui a à voir avec
le financement de l'assurance maladie
qui consomment le plus de soin une
personne de 80 des personnes d'une
quarantaine d'une quarantaine d'années
donc après bien sûr qu'il doit y avoir
de la solidarité mais on a dans ce cas
là on peut faire beaucoup de calculs
dire les retraités dans les années 70
ils ont racheté des biens immobiliers
avec des taux d'intérêt réels qu'ils
étaient négatifs ce qui est plus le cas
aujourd'hui puisque gers est une
équation qui est extrêmement large
donc ne mélangeons pas le cas des
pauvres retraités avec la question plus
globale de celle du rapport entre les
actifs aujourd'hui dans le contexte
actuel de la mondialisation et de
l'économie française qui objectivement
se porte moins bien que pendant les
trente glorieuses et les retraités dans
leur ensemble et c'est en gros un
certain nombre de points faire quand
même à préciser les trente glorieuses et
n'a pas failli à sa part été une période
bénie effectivement et les retraités
actuels n'ont pas connu la période bénie
où il n'y avait pas de chômage pas de ça
ici pas de cela je crois qu'il faut
quand même aux relations with a carrière
qui s'harmonisent rien quand même de
signaler que les trente glorieuses ça
s'est arrêté en 73 c'est au début des
années sur mes déchets mal de masse
celui le ch les années 80 et le chômage
a commencé à partir de ce moment là et
tous les gens n'étaient pas la retraite
hanquez retraités aujourd'hui ils ont
connu cette période
donc il faut pas si vous voulez dire les
retraités il n'y a pas de problème ils
ont vécu effectivement une idée
extraordinaire que l'anoci jura relais
pour faire venir j'ai entendu aussi que
certains disaient ils n'ont pas connu la
guerre d'algérie main dont on trouve un
petit peu n'importe quoi alors pour
venir si vous permettez sur la csg la
csg ce que nous disons et ce que nous
pensons c'est que monsieur rocard une
époque a créé la série
avec l'idée c'est un bon moyen de
financer la protection sociale et la
maladie en particulier
c'était une bonne idée et une bonne idée
qui s'est poursuivie qui était conduite
et on allait en connaît l'on connaît
aujourd'hui la situation de la csg on
peut considérer et ça me paraît tout à
fait logique qui a rien à dire que
monsieur macron considère qu'il est
souhaitable de continuer dans ce sens et
il restait effectivement des cotisations
maladie qui pesait sur les actifs de et
quelques courses on est ce qu il a dîné
chez makro si j'ai bien compris c'est on
va arrêter on va poursuivre le
financement de la sécu de la santé par
l'ensemble de la collectivité nationale
et les outils pour le faire il y en a
deux possibles 1 c'est la tva
l'autre c'est la csg c'est pas mon débat
il a choisi la csg très bien donc il
fait un système il augmente de 7% et
c'est la csg comme il se trouve que le
taux de csg et 1,7 pour cent c'est un
peu moins que les cotisations qui sont
supprimées et donc ça va se traduire par
une amélioration du pouvoir d'achat des
salariés n'est pas les retraités très
bien très bien mais ce qu'il ya c'est
que en plus de ça il y a eu un système
de compensation qui était fait pour les
fonctionnaires pour les indépendants
le résultat c'est que l'ensemble des
catégories s'est trouvée compenser si
vous voulez de cette augmentation
d'assiéger voire pour certains avec une
amélioration très bien je discute pas de
ça on ne discute pas il n'y a pas de
jalousie de notre part ce que nous
disons simplement c'est que y'a une
différence de traitement
pour nous ça ressemble un petit peu la
discrimination haro sur les retraités
seront ceux des retraités
et quand j'entends vous les retraités
vous pourriez quand même faire un petit
peu de solidarité vis-à-vis des plus
jeunes mais de qui se moque t'on de qui
se moque t'on les retraités solidarité
vis-à-vis de leurs amis les âges de la
vie de la société
regardez les retraités comme il y en at
il qui sont dans les associations
combien y en at il mais j'allais dire au
parlement ou au sénat il en reste encore
pas mal hein et c'est un regard d un
petit peu dans les communes fait
référence à autre chose sans un but
rageur de la solidarité jeudi sa
solidarité publique
vous faites référence et intrafamiliale
apprennent qu'on en a aussi atteint les
limites penser à une communauté comme un
diable une commune etc tout ça quand
vous regardez les conseils municipaux
khiati dans les conseils municipaux
d'une grande majorité de retraités avons
des actionnaires majoritaires du psg les
retraités n'ont pas d'utilité sociale
le pire est-il à venir pour les
retraités la question se pose
aujourd'hui avec cette hausse de la csg
cette éventuelle baisse des pensions
complémentaires on va y venir
hier patronat et syndicats se
réunissaient pour négocier alors on a
d'un côté le medef qui nous dit arrêtons
d'affoler les gens et on a d'un côté la
cgt qui nous dit les pensions vont bel
et bien baissé de 9% sur moins de 15 ans
vous nous confirmer cela oui elles vont
baisser
elles vont baisser de façon relative par
rapport à l'inflation
il n'y aura pas dans les dix ans qui
viennent une diminution des pensions
nominal au nombre de rôles et pensions
ne vont pas baisser mais elles vont
baisser par rapport à l'élévation du
niveau de vie ce qui est très
intéressant dans le débat d'hier c'est
que ça met bien en lumière ce que
maintenant absolument tout le monde fait
c'est-à-dire tout cas ceux qui
s'occupent de la retraite c'est à dire
que ce qui est prévu dans les futurs
décennies c'est une baisse très
importante en valeur relative par
rapport au salaire d'activité du niveau
des pensions
on passerait à peu près des trois quarts
le remplacement du salaire par la
pension à autour d'eux les deux tiers à
60 % ce qui est prévu c'est en
perspective on passerait de 14 % du pib
à 12 et demi pour cent du pib c'est
prévu sur les trente prochaines années
alors évidemment le montant nominal ne
va pas baisser mais d'après nos
projections à la cgt ce serait moins 9 %
sur 15 ans d'après les projections du
conseil d'orientation des retraites du
comité de suivi de retraite de l'agirc
et de l'arrco et les autres négociateurs
hier n'étaient pas d'accord stéphanie
muller non en fait l'idée c'est que
le/la or là on parle juste de la
retraite complémentaire réunion d'hier
ne parle que d'une partie de la retraite
sa retraite complémentaire agirc arrco
qui a en projet de fusionner pour
devenir un régime unifié le 1er janvier
l'idée c'est de conserver tous les
engagements
deux passes et il n'y a pas de
modification mais elle a une elle
conserve aussi la même contrainte le
régime unifié va conserver la même
contrainte d'agir car quo c'est-à-dire
les équilibres financiers agirc arrco
s'est éteint ce sont deux régimes qui ne
se sont jamais endettés qui ne font pas
recours à l'endettement il y à un
équilibre financier qui est inscrit et
donc il doit tenir compte en fait 7 pour
que ce régime fonctionne il va contre
tenir compte de l'évolution des
cotisants c'est à dire lorsqu'on est en
pleine crise lorsqu'on a connu en 2008
lorsque le taux de chômage augmente et
bien sûr la clé cotisations baisse sauf
qualifié nouveau dites moi si je me
trompe c'est que la variable
d'ajustement ça va être le niveau des
pensions et ça c'est nouveau
non non alors dit non je suis pas dans
le même sens que madame l'equilibre d'un
régime de retraite de répartition il ya
trois variables y en a trois une
quatrième si vous voulez 3une c'est le
niveau des pensions une autre c'est le
niveau des cotisations et une troisième
c'est l'âge de départ en retraite si les
trois variables
aujourd'hui on est dans un système où
alors l'âge de départ en retraite
c'était 65 ans que lundi 60 comme est
monté à 62
c'est pas dieu qui a dit que les
retraites doivent partir à 62 ans on
s'est écrit nulle part un dans les
tables de la loi
c'est pas indiqué et donc rien
n'interdit de penser qu' il puisse y
avoir alors sur une base systématique ou
sur une base volontaire
tu veux avoir une meilleure retraite à
restent au travail un peu plus longtemps
tue le ca te suffit par tout de suite en
train c'est un système alors c'est le
sida au cv noël c'est un système de
retraités ce n'est pas obligatoire - un
point de file active
c'est pas un point de vue de retraités
chez youtube fait le point de vue
d'europe de quelqu'un qui regarde la
société telle qu'elle est et qui
s'efforcent et d'avoir un point de vue
alors c'est ce qu'il faut dire sociétale
nous avons bien évidemment nous
associations de retraités à défendre nos
intérêts c'est clair mais nous avons
aussi des enfants et les enfants nous
parlent dans l'es4 il nous parle du 10
il explique on n'y comprend rien on veut
savoir qu'est ce qui se passe on aura
rien non mais je le sais et donc à
partir de ce moment-là associations de
retraités dont ils font nos intérêts ça
va de soi mais nous essayons également
d'avoir une vision plus globale il dû
dire que faudrait-il pour la société
française
et c'est pour ça que de la même manière
que je considère que la pratique de
monsieur macron concernant la csg est
tout à fait négatifs si vous voulez pour
les retraités
je dirais en même temps c'est bien comme
ça qu'il faut dire je trouve que sa
vision sur les retraites tel qu'il a
exprimée est plutôt favorable puisque
est en train de changer à l'heure
actuelle le point qui a été soulevée par
la cgt et c'est là où les autres ont
répondu que c'était de la mauvaise foi
c'est que en l'état il ya des
négociations annuelles justement pour
garantir l'équilibré des régimes arrco
qui sont pour l'ensemble des salariés du
privé et agirc qui en plus pour les
cadres au dessus si je crois au dessus
3000 euros de salaire et donc là on le
nouveau système prévoit un système à la
suédoise c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne en suède en disant tous les
ans il y aura en il y aura des
rencontres tous les cadrans tous les
quatre ans si j'ai bien compris et dans
là où il y aura des renégociations sur
les critères dont vous avez parlé il y
en a d'autres parce que c'est on peut
décider qu'il ya des appels à 120%
certaines années vous sur demande et des
cotisations en quelque sorte qu une
manière habile de pas dire que vous les
augmenter ça peut leur mettre de
l'apaisement mais voilà ça s'appelle un
toad apprennent ou une enfin pour le
commun des mortels ne sait quand même
une manière de procéder qui s'apparente
pour celui qui paye la cotisation à une
hausse de la cotisation est quoi qu'il
en soit donc en l'état on y avait des
négociations tous les ans et le
dispositif n'a pas vocation à baisser
c'est là où on peut parler d'une forme
de relative mauvaise foi la cgt il n'a
pas vocation à baisser les cotisations
il y aura toujours une réalité politique
qui s'imposera à ce que je sache les
retraités sont toujours la catégorie qui
votent le plus qu'aucun gouvernement a
dévoilé aucun gouvernement n'a intérêt à
se mettre à dos les retraités en
revanche dans le pilotage automatique
voilà effectivement le niveau des
cotisations peut être un moyen d'agir
mais qu'est ce qui se cache comme calcul
politique derrière c'est de dire bien
regardez là l'équilibré cette année qui
justifierait une baisse par exemple de
1% des cotisations de 10 donner le
chiffre que vous voulez le gouvernement
dira mais regardez on ne fait pas un
pour cent on le fait juste à 0 1% parce
que politiquement ce sera plus facile de
dire on aurait pu faire un parce que l'
équilibre nous aurait permis de faire un
on va juste faire 0-1
et voilà parce que de toute façon il
faut bien réussir d'une manière ou d'une
autre à équilibrer ces régimes là qui
doivent être équilibrés je vous laisse
répondre qu'on valait 1
ce positif ou le dispositif existe les
cieux l'on essayé une fois
précisément baisser les cotisations ses
amis tout le monde dans les rues ils ont
renoncé
donc la culture française étant ce
qu'elle est je doute que ça se passe un
jour même si le dispositif le prévoit en
pilotage automatique
ici en suède il ya eu baisse de
cotisations mais une fois et ça a été
annulé parce que parce qu'il ya un
mouvement social l'enjeu pour monsieur
macron et d'effectivement d'acclimater
un système à la suédoise en france ce
système à la suédoise inclus dans son
pilotage automatique
le fait de pouvoir baisser les pensions
en tout cas de les geler
aujourd'hui nous sommes en fait dans une
situation de gel des pensions
c'est à dire de baisse relative par
rapport à l'inflation et la lange eu une
un des enjeux des négociations d'hier
c'était y compris de la part du medef
c'est très clair de dire mais on
pourrait baisser les pensions
donc on anticipe la réforme 2018 pour
pour mettre en place un système plus
global qui l'a pèserait sur le niveau
des pensions le voit d'achat des
retraites des retraités
effectivement la variable d'ajustement
devient le niveau de vie des retraités 1
et le niveau des pensions
certains invités on jouera sur plutôt
sur les autres leviers c'est comme ça
que ça s'est passé intérêts composés
volet politique parce que justement hier
le sénat s'est opposé en commission à
cette hausse de la csg concernant les
retraités on va écouter le président ait
l'air de la commission des affaires
sociales alain milon les retraités qui
ne sont pas compensés par quoi que ce
soit tout le monde est compensée dans la
rose de la cge ne l'était pas on profite
du fait qu'ils ne sont pas compensés
pour leur dire ben non on vous met pas
les élyséens possède de celles chez
alors stéphanie muller c'est ce qu'il
faut y voir juste un calcul politique de
ces républicains qui a un électorat dit
on plus parmi les retraités ou est ce
qu'il ya vraiment deux différences de
philosophie
non c'est un modèle qui va être testé
que macron veut tester qui arrive à
point nommé
je parle d'un point de vue
macroéconomique c'est que on essaye et
la croissance et la reprise est là et on
s'aperçoit que la population qui est
plus à même à que consommer davantage
chez la population active
sachant que les retraités ont un taux
d'équipement qui est déjà élevé ils sont
une voiture une maison enfin globalement
si sévère de la route de condom qui se
dit je vais et ça tombe bien je vais
profiter du fait que bas les signaux
sont au vert le chômage baisse les
créations d'emplois sont en train de
repartir
eh bien on va donner du pouvoir d'achat
données d'une bouffée d'oxygène aux
salariés sur tous les salariés du privé
pour qu'ils consomment davantage donc la
mécanique peut effectivement cela
bayonnaise peut prendre et entretenir la
croissance à venir
oui nous avons juste eu de réaction par
rapport à ça ce que vient de dire madame
magie aucun souci en tant que retraité
associations de retraités je n'ai aucun
souci par rapport à ça que à l'occasion
de cette opération de transfert si vous
voulez sur la csg 1 parce que c'est une
opération de transfert sur la csg qui
vieillit alors on peut pas appeler un
dommage collatéral c'est plutôt un
avantage collatéral
tant mieux excellente chose ce que nous
disons nous c'est que les retraités
effectivement par rapport à il le voit
mal donc par rapport à ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait et de ce que lui disant on ne
demande pas que l'on supprime la csg
pour les retraités c'est pas ça qu'on
demande ce qu'on demande c'est que comme
pour les autres catégories
il y ait des compensations qu'ils soient
prévus et on a prévu des compensations
conforme à la hauteur des attentes et
des compensations qui me paraissent
logis je voulais donner ça va être
rapide une s'est il subsiste sur
certaines combine retraite des
cotisations maladie sur les régimes
complémentaires de retraite du privé
il ya une cotisation maladie on supprime
la cotisation maladie sur les actifs
ça serait pas ballot ça serait même
plutôt intelligente de la supprimer
aussi sur les retraités parce que autant
on peut dire on transfère sur la csg
très bien pourquoi pas faire aussi pour
les retraités et les retraités
apprécierez certainement que ce genre de
chose soit fait désirer points le
deuxième point
aujourd'hui les angles arrondis beaucoup
les retraités y coûte cher ils sont
malades ils sont vieux et c'est génial
tout ça hein ça coûte la peau des yeux
ice et celle arvine de la sécurité
sociale ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les complémentaires santé quand les
retraites les mutuelles cette éruption
la complémentaire santé des retraités
les retraités
leur coûte trois fois plus cher que pour
un actif trois fois et ça c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est un monsieur qui
s'appelait etienne caniard qui était le
président de la mutualité française
jusqu'au milieu de l'année dernière
il connaît bien il a fait les calculs
alors si vous voulez je peux pas vous
expliquer comment et pourquoi il ya
d'abord une loi evin qui dit que l'on
payé 50 % de plus c'est à dire que 1 un
actif qui devient retraités dans le
cadre du régime dont il peut payer 50%
de plus on peut demander 50 % de plus
très bien il ya eu un accord annie signé
un accord national interprofessionnel
signé par un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales la vôtre je
ne sais pas ils nous répondent à deux
minutes je voudrais encore entendre à
lévis est donc là on dit l'entreprise en
payent la moitié donc 50% de plus que
les produits faits main en plus pour les
actifs cédés que tu t'y si vous voulez
du revenu imposable
donc ce qu'on demande c'est que pour les
retraités ça soit également à hauteur de
50% déductibles du revenu imposable
c'est logique ça ne remet pas en cause
la csg tels que monsieur macron a décidé
de la mettre en place
ça nous paraît une mesure logique et je
peux vous affirmer que dirt et australe
en juin dernier
je suis empreint sur ce que vous disiez
non les retraités ne votent plus à
droite les enquêtes d'opinion montrent
que maintenant ils sont devenus très mac
revenir dans les dernières vagues
étaient peut-être ils changeront soit en
l'état
en l'état c'est ça et deuxième point je
pense qu'il faut pas s'enfermer dans des
débats en dix ans les retraités coûte
cher parce qu'il ya personne n'a envie
de se poser enfin tout le monde a des
parents ont des grands-parents en tout
cas on souhaite en avoir évidemment et
on s'imagine qui ce retraité un jour on
le souhaite on le souhaite aussi donc il
s'agit pas dire ils coûtent trop cher il
s'agit il ya un autre argument moi je
trouve et je parle pas d'eux des deux
points que vous venez d'évoquer qui
effectivement peut avoir du sens mais
c'est la vérité des prix sert qu'on vit
dans un système d'assurance sociale où
il n'y a pas de vérité des prix personne
est conscient de combien coûte
l'assurance maladie notamment et combien
coûtent les soins le fait que quand on
est un plus gros consommateurs on doive
payer un peu plus c'est un argument qui
est pas seulement de solidarité mais qui
est aussi utile pour le système parce
qu'on le voit très bien qu'il ya
énormément de gaspillage aussi dans ce
système là dans toutes les catégories
d'âge pour le coup mais que y ait cette
vérité des prix là je trouve que c'est
utile 5 secondes
juste quand même préciser que auparavant
il y avait quatre cotisant pour un
retraité que maintenant il y en à 2,2
pour un seul ça va ça va baisser dont
effectivement il ya quand même aussi une
pression qui est sur la population
active gilbert y adhèrent nous avons
tout à fait raison de mettre le doigt
sur la complémentaire santé des
retraités
si on regarde les choses et aussi un
problème à concrète c'est très important
plus de charges contre rien c'était
absolument fera l'objet d'une prochaine
émission merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat dans